from everything she says. It can't be that you don't show PDA,
but you talk about popping your white frats. Okay, that can't
be the same thing. That can't be the same person. Uh, I don't
like showing I don't like showing uh PDA, but also in college,
I got railed by all these white dudes. Really? >> Oh, hell
no. >> The dog The dog's leading away. The dog is doing
to her what she did to him.
Have you guys been following this? You guys follow the Akos Singh
situation? This guy with his wife that's like the the wife that's
crazy and and saying all of the the like totally ludicrous. It's
she she's basically like the most entitled person on earth. Okay,
if people wanted to rage, I don't know why they don't rage at
Akos Singh's wife. Okay, all the hate that Tactical Templar just
sent towards Pokemon needed to go at Akos Singh. Is it real?
It's absolutely real and has always been real. It was not rage
bait. It was not rage bait. I promise you it was not rage bait.
It because people went back and looked at a bunch of other stuff.
It's not rage bait. I swear to God it's not. It's actually crazy.
Oh, you should see the flagrant 2 subreddit. Apparently, all
of their videos as well on YouTube are getting comment bombed,
like downvoted. It's all about Akasha's wife. Akash and Aasha's
wife. Like, everybody's furious about this. If it was rage bait,
it it went too far. All right. Now, the best video I've seen
on this so far >> is the is the Abba and Preach videos.
Okay. Now, I haven't watched all of the ABBA. I didn't watch
the first one, but this this one is crazy.
All right. This one is crazy cuz Preach is like trying. It clearly
comes They must have started streaming recently. Okay, which
is kind of interesting. But Preach is like trying to defend her
early on and ABBA's not having it. All right.
Uh, Red Pill was dead until Myron had the massive knockout. Well,
that's the thing is everybody everything's coming up Myron Gaines.
Okay, Myron Gaines was right about everything according to anyone
who's been accused of assault or some form of crime. Okay, like
Myron Gaines was about to lose and then a couple of people got
into cases tectone destiny. All right. And then this Akash Singh
thing turned and Myron Gaines now looks like the like a hero
to a ton of the internet. It's wild.
Uh you say this Kger but they meme about it a lot which is the
brown table talk >> dude it's Akasha's wife Jada Pinket
Smith and then a fusion of Akash and Will Smith. >> More
clips [laughter] have come out. They look really weird. In fact
she's even responded to some of them [snorts] explaining why
she might have been dodging some kisses cuz like people made
a big meme. They made a compilation like the one I did. >> So
basically yes there's a big comp there's a compilation of Akash's
wife. Every time he goes to kiss her, she like turns away from
him every single time. >> And they basically just kept
clipping moments of her just running away from his kisses and
she wants to explain why. >> Create a narrative.
>> Also, she started responding, okay, which is not good.
>> Nothing. And then I'll also respond to the people saying,
"I don't like my husband because I turned away from a kiss."
I've never liked PDA, physical touch. I find it really overstimulating.
And so it's something I actually work through with my husband
because that's his love language. And I feel like for him, he
tries uh to do physical touch to regulate his emotions and I
find it really disregulating. So it's something we kind of work
through in high stress situations cuz I get overstimulated when
a lot of things are happening and like my mother-in-law is there,
my mom is there and Akash will tend to >> Okay, so she
just gets overstimulated. All right. Just gets way over stimulated,
guys. That's all it is. She doesn't find her husband repulsive
at all. Like I'm sorry,
this is an arranged marriage, right? I don't know if you guys
are aware of it, but this is an arranged marriage. And it's worked
out quite well for her financially, but I
if they're not doing a bit, she certainly has made it seem in
every possible way like she does not find this guy attractive.
>> See, when there's a lot of people around and sometimes
I'm overstimulated, so I'm just like, "Oh, so yeah, if you want
to know like my whole
psychosis
or whatever, then I can give it to you." But it's just annoying
that you guys create a narrative out of something that's sweet
for no reason whatsoever. Um because you're miserable in your
own >> I I can understand that could be a thing. But I
can understand that people like human beings are full of >> that
at the wedding mark I didn't have any expectation for that feeling
to increase. But that feeling has increased [music] where I feel
even more.
>> Dude, that's rough. That's rough when it's at the wedding,
right? That's That's tough. At the wedding,
bro, at the wedding. Does he have a picture of him kissing his
wife anywhere? I need some proof that they've ever kissed. Okay.
>> More love from him than I ever that I >> dude.
This is like photos. This is photos just by yourself. It's not
about PDA, bro. They're not He's not even They're like ships
passing in the night. Like ships passing in the night.
Our lips never to meet. never to directly collide. What is happening?
>> See, see, she's able to do it. All right. So, everybody,
>> that was very misaligned. That was
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think Aba was watching this one and he's
like, "Look, they can kiss." And then, AND THEN PREACH POINTS
OUT THEY'RE LIKE SHIPS PASSING in the night. They actually don't
connect here.
>> That was, you know, I'm just trying to help Akasha.
[laughter] >> You're not trying to >> Listen, I'm
just trying to help in any way I can. You're not >> Nobody.
Let's be real. And look, the whole over stimulation thing, >> I
get it. >> Uh, you know, oh, cuz Akash tries to kiss me
when we're in public. >> You know, there's a lot of those
clips where they're in private. It's just the two of them. >> If
you don't like PDA and there's a camera, even if it's nobody,
there's a >> and then he keeps trying every time. >> Yeah,
it's public. >> So, so, so, so wait, if you don't like
it, this is a thing, but he keeps trying to kiss her all the
time. >> And she's like, I don't like it, but he keeps
doing it. >> Yeah, because once it's one person's, it's
one's person's love language that don't match the other person's
love language. I've seen I've seen that.ve I've seen that >> together
for 10 years. I think at some point you have to adjust. No, >> that's
not how how life works necessarily. Like people don't >> So
I'm I was kind of on Preach's page where it's like that's a reasonable
explanation. But you tell me there's never been a time where
like at your wedding for your wedding photos, you're not kissing
for your wedding photos.
Really?
I that tells me something very specific. And I dude, if akos
can't stand up for himself, okay, for the wedding photos, it's
like, hey, don't you want a picture of you kissing your bride
in your wedding photos? Like, shouldn't you want that? Shouldn't
you need that? Isn't that something you should require out of
your wedding photos?
You talk what? How? How could you just allow that not to happen?
>> Be like, "Oh, yeah. After 10 years,
okay, I'm just going to accept that love. People still struggle
with different stuff." >> Uh, what? >> But yeah,
>> no, hold up. So, wait. Your partner says, "I don't like
it when you touch me this way." And at 10 years in, you're going
to keep touching them the way they don't like. So,
>> but they hold on, hold on. They could say that's not
necessarily how this would go, right? I think in a relationship,
you could do it like, "Okay, this is we have different love languages."
Okay. Um, sometimes I'm going to pull away, but don't stop. Like,
please keep I've I've had people say this with when they have
like um like hang-ups around stuff. Like, don't stop trying.
I I want to get over it. I feel like it's a bad thing. Like,
I have some anxiety around this, but don't stop trying. I want
to get over it. Right. No, I didn't cover Sneo versus Zerk already.
We'll cover that in just a little bit. But that's like a totally
understandable thing. That's It's not It's not like um
It's not like she doesn't want it. She just said that's not my
love language. It makes me feel a little anxious. But she might
think that's something she wants to overcome that she's always
had that problem. You don't know. But we do kind of know. Like
I I'm sorry, man. There's a lot of other indicators here that
she just doesn't find her husband attractive. She's kind of grossed
out by him. >> I'm not going to do it, but some people
do. Yes. And that's not everybody is is all there.
They had a pinned comment saying it's looked down upon to show
PDA in Indian culture. Okay, where's this woman's Indian accent?
Has this woman even been to India? Okay, I'm I'm I know she's
been to India. If she had an arranged marriage, she's been to
India multiple times. But she clearly is like a western person.
She's clearly not like entrenched in Indian culture from everything
she says. It can't be that you don't show PDA, but you talk about
popping your at white frats. Okay, that can't be the same thing.
That can't be the same person. Uh, I don't like showing I don't
like showing uh PDA, but also in college I got railed by all
these white dudes. Really? >> They're in the way of doing.
You know what I mean? >> I think that when I'm watching
someone propose in that moment right there and like you're reeling
away as quick as possible and ready to show every that don't
look like over stimulation. >> How big is this? >> Big
enough for you to shut up every time I tell you. >> Thank
you, >> dude. That's that's also just to be clear. That's
a crazy thing to say while you're prop. Could you imagine this
is him like reproposing to her? That's an insane thing to say
while you're
Uh yeah, it's big enough ring for you to shut the up. >> How
big is this? >> It's big enough for you to shut up every
time I tell you.
>> Big enough for you to shut up every time I tell you
to. Bro, you're a comedian. If that was a joke, where's your
timing?
If if if that was a joke, I don't know what to tell you. find
a different job.
>> I CAN'T WATCH. I CAN'T WATCH. >> LOOK AT THIS
ring of >> By the way, that's their soundboard. By the
way, look, Abas AB is like trying to find his soundboard. He
hits a soundboard for the floor. Hold on. Watch. Watch his hand
go to A >> WATCH. I CAN'T WATCH. >> I FIND THAT VERY
funny that they No more creaky floorboards, but we have a soundboard
for it. So, you'll never be without it. Okay. Awesome. >> Look
at this ring. >> No, but there's No, no, no, no, no. That's
unfair. >> She was dodging that [laughter] Neo the Matrix.
That's unfair. That's unfair. That's unfair. That's unfair. Hey,
bro. You cannot dictate how over stimulation looks like. >> I
disagree. I think someone going on streams being so comfortable
talking about every thing in the world, yapping their way without
Ezy hesitation. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> And
the moment their husband comes to even touch them a little bit,
they're reeling away like this over stimulation. There's a part
of that which plays into a lot of the other stuff you said, which
is like he's not very attractive. When I think about m I don't
think about my husband. Sometimes I get so
>> painfully nostalgic for college. I was popping my [laughter]
I'm living my best life in these white boy frat houses. I'm actively
trying to have an or because and you haven't seen Nav yet, but
wait till you see him. And it's kind of weird cuz I'm talking
about your husband. I just know that Nav's
is like at least 10 in. Okay, I have two but stories. So one
time I met this guy on Tinder and I made the dump I like woke
up in the morning but stories >> was a little sore. >> Oh
my god. >> And I remember like >> what kind of do
you watch when you use a >> Um okay not going to lie. I
don't watch >> what I just think of like my old >> Oh
this this is a new one that I hadn't seen before and this is
a rough one >> while I'm like doing it. Wait, that's kind
of baller but I could never do >> Yeah. And so I was >> you
want to just say
>> I could never just think about my husband is what she
says. Holy. Did he know about this? No, I doubt it because years
ago years ago, okay, he was telling stories about how he was
like this old unattractive or or he was like this old guy who
had an awkward, you know, mid20s, early 20s. He was like ugly.
He didn't glow up until later in life, right? And he thought
it was so cool that him and his wife lost their vcards to each
other. Little did he realize she was getting like she was getting
like triple penetrated white fratouses. Okay. He grew up. Yeah.
Apparently he's really ugly, really fat when he was a kid. Okay.
And he carries that energy into later life cuz he's straight
up like
Oh, he's just brutal. Okay. It's brutal. It's brutal. This woman
is somebody you should actually get upset about. Okay. This is
rough. >> Just over stimulation or you want to buy into
that narrative, but I don't buy it. That's just like that's the
most generous like
>> he's a dog. Yo, how many times a happy barking a big
dog all the time? >> That's me. That's >> is kissing
dogs PDA.
>> I'm just I'm just asking. She kissed that dog with more
enthusiasm.
>> Stop. He's already dead. He's already dead. Stop.
Stop.
is that dumb,
>> dude. This guy, honestly, this could be the thing that
like topples the entire
uh what do you call it?
>> Why did I just lose I just lost the name of the podcast.
Andrew
Schultz's podcast. Un unfiltered. No. Why did I just lose that?
It might top of the whole podcast. They're getting like mass
downvoted. Fragrant flag fragrant. Not fragrant. God, you got
me. You got me to say it. Stephen Jelly flag fragrant. Okay.
He it might top of the whole pocket. Like people are freaking
out about this. They don't respect anybody who respects this
guy. It's so
bro that's how powerful the gender war is right now. That's how
powerful like inceldom is right now. Okay. And femaleeldom. Trust
me on the women's side. There's no way you get this this movement
on the men's side without the same movement on the women's side.
Okay? And somebody like Far, if you guys remember, one of my
biggest criticisms of Far, she's basically she was like a gender
warrior. She was always like exacerbating that stuff, right?
She is just tactical Templar, but she is more attractive. Okay,
that's it. That's the only difference between them. They're the
same person in different sides.
She kissed that dog with more enthusiasm than she ever has that
soft male. Her husband probably looks at that dog with >> Jeez,
I wish I knew what your lips feel >> I can't. It was a
long [laughter] time. OH, HELL NO. >> DUDE, the dog The
dog's leading away. The dog is doing to The dog is doing to her
what she did to him. >> Dude, the dog gets over stimulated.
>> I mean, if you look at a dog, it's is it's not on the
lips. [laughter] The dog >> The dog is over stimulated.
>> Let's go.
>> Wrong W wrong. Let's go. >> When you get a bunch
of >> We're all Listen, this is one place we can actually
all be incels. Okay, this is the one person I think even women
could be incelss at this point watching this woman specifically.
Even women would just be like, "Oh my god, maybe incels have
a point. Holy, this is black pilling.
There's somebody who this happened. This this woman has set back
feminism like a decade solo. She managed to do it. Normally I
don't go in for all that like, oh, she's a bad example of the
class thing, but this woman has done it. She's managed to successfully
set feminism back a decade by herself." Absolutely crazy. comments.
Like for example, that >> Hey, you still here from the
last time? >> Um, I'm I'm going to skip this one time.
Okay, I just want to keep the momentum of the video going. Thank
you.
>> Preach is awesome. Love that guy. >> The worst
day of >> Also, never want to know more about him in my
entire life. Please, nothing from nothing from Preach's private
life ever comes out. Please, just I just want to think there's
like a few good people on the internet. Every time I learn about
someone's private life, it's like, "Oh, they're not actually
the person I thought they were." Okay, just [__]
Please keep your private life private. I never want to know more.
Just let me believe there's one good wholesome person here for
me is >> Oh, I know this. Go >> hack day. No, >> it's
Akasha's birthday. >> And I feel it cuz she's being nice
to me all day. And by like 8, like 10 p.m. I can feel her getting
just like I'm so ready for this to be over. [laughter]
>> Dude, I like that in of itself is telling. I don't know
if anybody points this out. Okay. But that in and of itself is
telling. Around the time we'd be [__] I can tell
she's done with it already. Around the time we'd be having Yeah,
she's over it.
That's great. That's insane. 8 10 p.m. Yeah, around the time
we'd be on my birthday. Yeah, that's it's over. You could I'm
I'm just going to call it I'm going to call the easy lowhanging
fruit. This guy has never received a [__] from his
wife ever in his entire life. Ever. There's no way. She can't
even kiss him on the lips. You think she's going to kiss him
on the on the mushroom tip? No shot.
No way. It's like the I turned back into a pumpkin at 12:01
May 5th and she's so relieved that she gets to be mean again.
>> Okay, May the 4th is Akash's birthday and every year
I dread it because I have to be nice [laughter] the whole day
and I have to get him something and I have to also be nice and
do like acts of kindness. [laughter]
>> Well, it's really hard.
Is this also a result of her being over stimulated by her feeling
need to be mean all the time >> just want to just check?
>> For her it's really hard for me. >> She needs
to just, you know, >> listen, I'm just used to being treated
like a princess all day every day. So that one day that I don't
>> Oh, what torture. >> Yeah, it's hard.
[snorts] >> I'm sorry. Just PTSD. >> PTSD for me.
For me, this is personal. Like the whole like I'm used to being
treated like a princess thing.
>> Just a It's a
personal thing. Let me take a second. Let me collect myself.
>> Is this birthday? He >> the incel pastor ra is
just like flurring up. Okay. He's just like I I He's like He's
like Tone, but he can identify it. Okay. And I respect that.
Techone. He sees women say, he gets triggered and he's like off
down a side road of complaining about Only Fans again. All right.
And his ex. But Abba's like, "You know what? I'm getting trauma.
I'm getting like some some triggers here. I'm I'm picking something
up. Give me a sec. I'll collect myself. I won't make it about
another woman." I appreciate that. Okay. >> He didn't really
give a either cuz he gave me this ring and he was like, "I've
done enough." >> Oh god. >> Yeah. What are you? Look
at the ring. We went to church. >> But did you get her
flowers?
did you sketch? That's my last That's my last thing that I got.
I got nothing. [laughter] No bully. She's a sketch. >> You
know what? >> That's That's preach breaking. Okay. Preach
was like trying to play devil's advocate. He was trying. He was
trying. He was trying. Oh, [__] this [__]
me right now
>> is that my husband I he said I just ordered your Christmas
gift. I was like oh what did you get me? He's like I'm not going
to tell you. So I'm like okay
you know trying to guess and then he and he's like what did you
get for me?
>> Excuse me. >> The audacity. [clears throat] >> The
entity.
>> The entitlement.
The audacity.
I'm a little taken aback and I just want to know if anyone any
females have ever experienced this. >> Yes. They're all
going to say yes. >> No, I >> the entitlement. >> I
only want to hear females. I >> to be honest, at least
one woman in Aasha's family
hates him. Okay, that he could have gotten a heads up from basically
anybody on what kind of person this woman was, right? Somebody
knew the way Indian families work and somebody knew and that
person decided to remain silent and let Akos like deal with this
grenade like she they watched Akos get handed like a briefcase
that had a bomb in it and they knew the bomb was in it and they're
like you know what that's karma [__] akos like on
them akos like threw some poop at them in India when they were
kids okay back in Mumbai and they're like you know what
accept that suitcase yeah that looks that's a great suitcase
buddy that's a that's a great suitcase you should keep at that
briefcase with the bomb in it. Yeah, it looks good. >> I
only want to hear female. >> Yeah. No trans women >> because
it's like I'm sorry. Like first of all, how many weekends were
you gone this year, Akash? How about >> How many weekends?
>> I don't know. Many.
at least out of 52 weekends. And I do
>> Living by yourself, you do everything. She does everything,
guys. She She waters the plants. She >> I don't know what
[laughter] >> what was that stopping >> my girl.
You can't complain to someone that you're doing everything
which includes cleaning the apartment. Complaining that that
person is not there. You're picking up. >> Bro, Preach
thinks she cleans the apartment. Dude,
I hate to tell you this. I hate to tell you this. Preach
that don't clean [__] that they they're rich enough.
They 100% have a maid service, right? They that don't clean [__]
I guarantee Aasha's probably got a piece of that flagrant podcast
and I Dude, there's no WAY SHE >> AFTER YOURSELF. YOU'RE
NOT DOING EVERYTHING. YOU'RE PICKING UP AFTER YOURSELF. HE'S
NOT THERE.
>> DISHES YOURS. CLOTHES ON THE GROUND
>> But you're missing the point. She's a princess. A princess
shouldn't have to clean for herself. So, the fact that she's
even doing it is proof of her commitment to you. You wouldn't
get it because you ain't never dated a princess. It's okay. >> Thank
God [laughter] she even Okay. >> Thank God. >> Y
don't y'all don't know THIS MINDSET. >> THANK GOD. >> There's
some dads out there that talk to their daughters like this and
like make them think a man's supposed to do this >> You're
picking up after yourself, my girl. You're not doing everything.
I >> If you don't AND YOU WANT TO PICK up less, do less.
What you want me to do? Let's uh let's get into the mind of Akash
because he's done some interviews about this and some >> Oh
boy. I dude I I'm guessing they have other videos on this situation.
I have not seen them. It's good coverage though. It's great coverage.
In fact, in fact, I don't know. I don't even know how you miss.
Basically, everybody just gets to be as hyperbolic as they want
about this person cuz you you can't react appropriately. I found
a repost of the Akash S. Oh, this is them. >> Did a song
like this? Okay. Okay. We'll check out online. >> Are you
a people pleaser? >> Right. That's when you keep scores.
>> And she likes being pleased like openly. My wife is
the most self-aware. It's It's like amazing. She laughs at herself.
She's incredibly self-aware. She's like, "Yeah, I'm high maintenance.
It is what it is." Like, I know if you want me to buy, >> bro.
He
was this was this a part of like Was this a part of a response?
Dude, this guy looks rough. This [snorts] guy's going through
it. Okay. This guy This guy used to look This guy used to look
like he was energetic. He was loving life. Bro, I hope it hasn't
seeped into his comedy. Spoiler alert, it seeped into his comedy.
>> I'm not going to apologize, but yeah, that's where the
the scorekeeping comes >> I feel like I'm doing this. >> But
I'm not doing it for you. I'm doing it so you tell me I'm good
enough. You know what I mean? That's a very different thing,
>> I'm not giving to her for her. I'm doing it so she thinks
I'm good enough. Just sit with that for a second. And all the
all the 25k gift. >> The sad thing is I feel like his wife's
aware of this. And no, no, no. He's not proud. He is probably
identifying that he's got like a complex. Okay.
>> All this other stuff. It's not like it's like I need
you to know that I'm capable or what >> is it a bit? It's
not a bit. I'm telling you it's not a bit because it's been a
thing. There are clips going back years. It's not a bit. It is
not a bit. There is basically clips of everybody calling this
woman a [__] as they were together. Like as they
met, as they were together. It goes years into the past. Their
wedding photos, arrange marriage, their wedding photos have her
turning away from him. There's no way they set up a year a long
con here where Akos goes and says Myron's life's like all of
his beliefs are wrong. Like why would he set himself up as a
bit to be humiliated and that's crazy >> of you.
And it's funny too because you see how he gives and he gives
and he's like are you now going to reciprocate like and she's
like
why don't you do >> Have you ever watched Real Housewives
of New Jersey?
Have you ever watched Real
>> I I I said it earlier. ABBA is like actually trigger.
He's like actually totally dissociated right now. He's like totally
dissociated. He's going through some old relationship he had.
He's like running the highlights of him being in like a similar
situation. Almost certainly nowhere near as bad, but he's just
running the highlights of that and he's just like going through
his mind. He's playing he's in the the theater in his mind. Okay.
Just watching the film >> New Jersey season 3, the Christmas
episode when Melissa got the shoes.
>> Telling you it's there's just he's somewhere else. >> She
got like a Louis Vuitton baggage and she got a gold Rolex and
she got a recording studio.
Did Joe ever ask her where's my gift? >> This is jarring,
bro. Oh, my grand example, Real Housewife of New Jersey.
>> You know the show where they're famous for being like
totally entitled, like completely talentless.
You know that show, Real Housewives of New Jersey? >> Well,
he said it in the in the clip where about the ring. >> My
my heroes are all >> the whole introduction was about that.
This is why earlier when you brought up the over stimulation,
I had an issue with it cuz I can understand over stimulation
and some isolated incidents. But when you have a consistent trend
where something you don't like is about to happen, I get it.
You know, my partner might ask me to do things I don't enjoy
like holding hands. I I hate it. Like like >> But you hate
it. I'm not going to >> No. No. No. No. >> Like this?
>> Like this?
>> THE GUY THE GUY says he hates holding hand. He proceed
into holding my hand. getting every single question wrong on
a multiple choice test seems pretty
Um, okay, you could say that. I'm telling you that there's just
years and years of footage of this woman being a [__]
It's It's who she is. Uh, like what could they have possibly
maybe maybe the thing that could be rage bait here, like intentional
rage bait, is her saying that she was a in college.
Now, based on everything else about her, all the actual moments
where it's like not a bit where she's clearly just acting like
a totally entitled. Um, based on all of those moments, I'd say
probably not. That's probably also real. And him acting like
a
No, he is a No, he is. Is there a single picture of them actually
kissing? Dude, it's like years. It's There's no way. You can't
invent this. You can't You can't invent the track record if she
was just like brand new. But there unfortunately there are a
bunch of indications from the past of this exact kind of dynamic.
>> My partner having a sweet moment.
>> I'm telling you this is the one I'm positive on. We
can actually go hard on this one. My money is still on either
a bit. Okay. Why? Why is your money on that Porter Bellar? You
understand that if somebody consistently is the same way, that's
probably just who they are, right? Like there is no indication.
There's no indication there is any other person there. Okay.
All right. I will overcome my discomfort with that for her and
that moment. My thing isn't even >> "Yeah, Aba gets it,
right? Oh, if I'm like if I've got discomfort, then in like certain
moments, I'll I'll overcome that." It's not that it's it's not
my love love language, but it's not important for me to be happy
all of the time, right? Like I could do something that makes
me a little uncomfortable to make the other person happy, obviously.
Um I don't think we're engaging in somebody's fetish. Again,
arrange marriage.
Arrange marriage. Arrange marriage. Arrange marriage. They didn't
plan this. >> I go, "Did they not make it up?" >> Maybe
maybe this stuff with like the husband, maybe there's a dynamic
that is real there. Possibly the dynamic is real, but there's
so much wrong here. The dynamic and the she says that about wanting
to [__] with the dudes that doesn't even like register
compared to like the money compared to her level of entitlement
on everything, right? The thing almost doesn't even register
>> or whatever. It's like came to pick. Okay. At least
like hug the properly do something. Yeah. Like like to me the
inability to compromise
on your
>> um it's in the flacco video that we're going to watch.
>> Comfort for someone else's comfort is what tells me
a lot. I agree with you that some people are not in PD. I'm not
expecting everybody but like you don't even see the try. Maybe
I'm too idealistic. I'm not [laughter] asking.
>> Listen, I actually don't think that's true. I think
there are a couple versions where let's say hypothetically I'm
going to I'm going to entertain this. Okay. Let's say hypothetically
she is actually not into PDA. She like is very uncomfortable
with it. And her way of like not leaning out of it is when he
makes it clear he's coming in for some kind of PDA, she like
leans in with her cheek a little bit. I think there are moments
where she does that versus like totally fleeing where that might
have been a compromise that they worked on. >> For I don't
think so. But like >> but that's man that is like a level
of cope that I don't think is rational that I'm just like if
you wanted to make the argument that's where the argument would
be. I don't necessarily want to make that argument cuz it's a
bit uncomfortable to watch. >> Did you say if we have a
son? >> I said you said our son is going to be soft and
I said he won't. >> Uh, our son is going to be soft. >> You're
5'7. I'm 52. >> Physically physically soft would annoy
me, but emotionally soft would really I can't handle. >> This
is why Ara said he needs to have girls cuz he's not going to
love his >> I won't love a soft son. >> Okay, man
up. >> Soft guts. Instead of instead of the vine boom,
Abbas's just got like the creaky floor. That's his his punctuation
thing. Okay. Instead of a vine boom, he just does the creaky
[laughter] floor. To be fair, I think that's how they used it.
That's literally they didn't like intentionally do it all the
time, but soft ninja hating on soft ninjas. Come on, man. Yeah.
Although, actually, the amount of emotional turmoil he must be
going under, I don't know if you can call him soft even. Doesn't
seem very soft. Seems like he's like legitimately going through
it right now. Like legitimately just like me. with me >> was
rough. >> If your man is weird about periods, that's a
red flag. Break up with him immediately. No pun intended because
when I was in college, I dated this guy. You know, he didn't
want to fool around when I was on like the heaviest days of my
period. Okay, totally understandable. I get that. And I was like,
"Oh, great. Good news. My period ended. Like, we can like have
fun tonight." Blah, blah, >> dude. Also, she just makes
it so clear that she's like extremely thirsty,
right? Like that's and then privately
it's clearly not like I don't know man. >> He was going
down on me looking around down there like more blood can sometimes
come out even if your period is over. I swear to God like I thought
my period was done. He like looked at me with so much disgust
>> and I'll never forget that moment. Like I felt so ashamed
and so dirty and like he was like how could you do this to me
and all this stuff ruined the night and like whatever and we
he was my boyfriend at the you guys. So rage bait serves a purpose.
It makes you money. They are undermining Akasha's entire fan
base. They are destroying Akasha's career doing this. Unless
they have some like we put this in a in a safety deposit box
like two years ago to show you that this was not real. She's
actually like crushing this guy's career. this guy. And this
guy, by the way, we're going to hear about somebody went to one
of his comedy shows and apparently he went off about this topic.
Okay, so he's not even handling it well himself. This will destroy
him. He is not that guy. He's not that ninja. Okay, he can't
handle it. No, no, no. Sometimes people are just self-destructing.
Sometimes they've made decisions in their life and things are
just falling apart. Okay, that's what's happening here. That
is absolutely what's happening here. Just because you don't know
the reason doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
I'm telling you any reason that could exist here doesn't make
sense. There is no reason to destroy like economic freedom for
oh we have like something else going on. It doesn't make sense.
It literally can't possibly make sense. You guys are hypothesizing
the weirdest fetish in the world for a guy who didn't even try
to for years and years and years. I think it's him saying for
years they were each other's first. There's that. There's so
many things here. Okay. There's so many things going on here.
So many. It's so crazy that people this one with Pokemon when
I hear when I see things that are like consistent with you know
this being um like real her being that entitled I'll like take
that and run with it right if there are but with this there's
literally nothing to show there's anyone else there's nothing
>> the time I was just like so depressed I went home and
like I called my sister and I was like I have to tell you something
like this happened to me and she literally was like so
and I was like what do you mean she was like Jesse That's so
normal. Like, >> so just bleed in that mouth. Just do it.
Just do it. >> So, my question is, my question is, my question
is,
[laughter] >> I got to go through that whole thing >> My
question is, my question is, my question is, >> dude, if
these guys are doing this live, if they've like started live
reacting to things, this setup is so good. This is like going
to I feel like this is going to send their channel to the next
level. Unironically, like this is actually really good content.
>> Was eating. They're most people listen when they react
they don't add all that much. These guys are adding a lot. I
like it. I like it a lot. >> And then you still spotting.
Right. So
when he got up and kissed you, you swerve. We have to find that
guy and ask >> Is that all these stories? You She's also
a virgin.
>> She was over stimulated. >> Never forget that.
Okay. Did she say that's normal? >> What's normal? Spotting.
It's not spotting. It's normal. No, >> no, no, no. eating
a girl. >> Well, the thing is, yeah, I understand this
check check checks off every box. I understand that's usually
the reason you would say that this is scripted, but when that
happens, there's not somebody who's being totally undermined,
who is already the bread winner who already has them set like
economically. As long as he could keep milking his podcast for
a couple more years, they're like set for life. There's risking
that for this is insane. Would be totally insane. >> Loud
and like getting blood on you. That's that's like a normal experience
>> a [groaning and screaming] yo boys being boys man you
like you oh well you can eat your steak you can eat your steak
with a little bit of blood in it but not your girlfriend >> like
the level of the sometimes there are kinks that are like borderline
life destroying
possible okay
that's that's possible there's like some borderline the there's
some borderline stuff there that can happen that like life destroying
like you get so financially um you get so like into fom you spend
all your money you get into debt or something there are things
like that. Okay. But but
oh, I don't know what to tell you, man. Like,
there's almost nobody that this happens to. There's nobody who
like becomes rich and famous and totally destroys their life
for this [__] Um or it's like incredibly rare. No,
I'm not accusing him of that. >> Come on, man. >> Listen,
I have no problem with periods. It's not something that bothers
me, but eating a girl out just before, right around, or just
after, I would never. And almost every woman I've ever been with
has been very sensitive about that possibility. So they tell
me not to. So I just I don't know. Maybe maybe I'm unaware. Maybe
this is more normal experience. Coagulated,
>> you know, a little clumpy. >> It's medium rare.
>> I didn't know that [__] >> Medium
rare with a little bit of blood pudding. Okay, what are we doing
here? >> God, these clips are so brutal. They're so bad.
>> The idea of asking a girl to sign a prenup incredibly
offensive. Okay.
Now,
>> like these ones I believe are rage bait, but these ones
don't affect Akos. Okay. These ones I do believe are rage bait.
I could believe it. I would believe it. I do believe it. But
these ones are not like the critical. These are just like icing
on the cake. There's just icing on the cake. Okay, we already
know she's a total We already know Akasha is a total without
this stuff getting added on. Is this like partially a Yeah, you
can see by her smile she thinks funny, but also she would never
sign that video.
>> Dude, Abba Abba's out here spitting
>> She really enjoys this bit of like, yo, my husband going
to do what the I say and I don't cook and I don't clean and I
don't do this and I don't work. Like, she enjoys the fact that
she can open >> and she had a wet in college. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Like she enjoys having this audacity to be wet. I mean
blood.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I Why? Why? Why would you? >> Someone
to sign a prenup [laughter] because I had some like booming
>> Then I would be like, "Yeah, can you just sign this
prenup?" Because like I don't want to like lose all my money.
But then like if a guy asked you to sign a prenup, I would be
like I would call off the wedding. Like I would literally call
off the wedding. >> You would have called off the wedding
if I asked you to sign a prenup. >> Yeah. Like I'm not
even joking. >> Yeah. She's not even joking. Yeah, >> she's
not. I don't think she is. I was trying to be generous at first,
but yeah, some be but I think underneath it all, I think she
just
>> charging Jim, you're just saying your feelings, but
you're trying to act like it's a logical position. You're just
saying your feelings. You could say, listen, Porter Beller has
the same position as you. But when I asked him why, he said intuition.
He just said that's what I think. He didn't try he didn't try
to justify it or pretend to be logical. He said that's that's
like just my feeling and I'm not going to get rid of that feeling.
But you're you're sitting here trying to argue that like, oh,
uh, I can see her with a knife inserting into the body. That's
our disagreement. No, it's not clear. It's not clear. When I
ask you for evidence, you you just can't say anything.
Evidence would be her saying it's a bit some indication that
she does have actual like um affection for him, some claim of
anything. Yeah. See, you're just going to keep saying your feelings
over and over again and say that it's just obvious. Okay. >> There's
some dislike there. >> And I could get it. Um uh if I'm
putting myself in her shoes, >> I just it will help you
in your life if you can discern your feelings from things you
can prove and then express which one is happening in any given
moment. Just letting you know. >> I'm princess. Okay. I
could imagine that if I'm a bad and I'm young and you're 31,
a bit of a loser
and you know out of shape, you want to be with me, you have to
promise me a good life and I will grant you the honor of getting
That wouldn't be a mixed race baby. They're both Indian as far
as I know.
>> white frat boys sloppy seconds.
>> Was I a virgin? As far as you're concerned, don't ask
questions, stupid. You know that if we stop working together,
I'm keeping 100% of the
>> I'm not joking. I'm serious.
>> The what? [snorts] >> Have you seen the flavor
channel?
>> Look at these. Look at these. >> More dislikes
than there are likes. Let me like it just to show them some love.
And all [laughter] Well, we came here for the aos wife comments
and I'm not disappointed. Akos married the that's going to be
someone's wife one day. >> All the comments are literally
about >> dude pop and pee for the frat house. This is crazy
boys. LIKE YOU YOU GUYS HAVE to understand that this is everybody's
like oh it's a bit it's a bit that was clearly going to destroy
him that clearly undermines everything he's ever said. Makes
him look like a complete
You're telling me you did that intentionally like in a calculated
fashion? Okay. Okay. I mean, okay, that's a level of psychopathy
that I've never witnessed. >> This was nine 10 days ago.
>> Okay, if I go back and I go to the other episode
Oh, I did dislike this one. Uh, >> they can't they can't
say when it was a bit. Okay, they can't say when it was a bit.
They just They have a feeling. >> this one has six. >> Then
why post it? Because she's an entitled [__] She doesn't
understand what she's doing and he's too much of a cuck to stop
her.
Literally just what's happening here is what's happening. I understand
why you want to pull but some people want to point away or sorry
pull away.
She can't think about the outcome for another person and he just
wants her to be happy. That's he he doesn't have his own happiness
scale. He just wants her to be happy. >> 400 day. Hey,
somebody released the Akos files. [laughter] >> Yeah, I
was
that was my favorite. I got to admit. >> So that's been
what's been going on with them. They've just kind of been catching.
But I'm sure they're not stressed. Like I know folks will think
it's like groundbreaking. Oh, look at >> Doesn't matter
cuz people are people are people are are talking about it and
all
>> Oh yeah. Was the Jada Pink and Smith stuff a bit when
Will Smith walked up and slapped the [__] out of
Chris Rock? Was that a bit? That's a cautious future. Okay. Will
Smith is the ghost of a cautious Christmas future. He's about
to get up and slap Andrew Schultz when he talks about this woman.
All right. And then it's gonna end. Hold on. Give me a second.
Give me a second. Where are we going? Okay, this is a good video.
This is a great video, but Oh, hold on. Song. Listen to the song.
Okay, apparently they did did a quick song. Let's check it out
real quick. And then I'm going to
J was promoting her pod probably.
Doesn't mean it was a bit, right? It's obviously not a bit, but
we are going to Yeah, you're saying something that is true. You
can do something bad and it not be a bit like you're not faking
it. Bit means fake means you're scripting. It means it's not
organic.
>> Now I'm hurt.
You are popping >> every week.
>> There's going to BE SOME DANCING
>> EVERY WEEK.
I ain't divorcing you. Can't afford to pay me. Embarrassing me
on a dead
not as fragrant. >> Got my wallet.
>> Got my wife. Yeah, she bad. >> She don't like
me. Yeah, she brown. >> That's all right. >> I'm
a s. Got my wallet.
>> Got my wife. >> Yeah, she bad. >> She don't
like she brown. >> That's all right.
That's all right.
>> That's all right. >> Make sure she got good teeth.
Huh? Huh? Huh. Y'all let social media ruin your wives. Oh no.
Ruin your husbands. Oh no. Ruin your marriages. Oh no. Ruin your
lives.
For free.
>> I could make these songs all night long. >> I'm
going to do a set. I'm going just play in the background.
MY WIFE.
>> SHE DON'T LIKE IT. She brown. >> That's all right.
>> Got my wife. >> Got my wife. >> Got my wife.
>> She don't like it.
That's all right.
That's all. [music] That's all right.
>> Little drops.
What a beautiful moment. What a beautiful ring. What a beautiful
ring. >> Amazing. You love to see it.
All right. All right. All right. All right. Now, that's a great
video. Okay.
That's a great video. But I've got another video here from one
of the best of the drama game. Okay. I I hated him for a long
time or didn't hate him, but I was a hater.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. It's Flaco. Okay, Flaco
does great work. I I I think I need to subscribe to Flaco's channel.
Okay, I do. I need to subscribe. Flaco's got some extra clips
here. All right,
he's got some extra clips and
they're not good. All right, I'll try to skip through what is
here for for like extra sorry, stuff we've already watched, but
he's got some unique clips. All right. Some unique clips going
on. And he the thing I like about Flaco is Flaco is a digger.
Okay. Flaco 100% digger. He has all of the clips. He has all
of the the unique stuff. He goes deep and he figures it all out.
Okay. >> Akos finally responded back to the humiliation
ritual his wife has been putting him through and it's not looking
good for our boy. Man, this is actually a really sad story and
it doesn't bring me joy in even reporting on this, man. Cuz I
have nothing against >> Do you have a cold? Yes, I'm coming.
I'm recovering from being sick. I'm I literally I've had like
I swear to God, I've had like a gallon and a half of water already.
>> Akos, he just married quite possibly the most horrible
human being I think I've ever witnessed on this internet. We
don't have to rehash everything that has happened over the last
week. But let's just say over the last week, we have learned
more about Akash and his relationship and his marriage than any
of us ever. And that's because we were introduced to Akash's
wife, >> Jasine, through her podcast. And let's just say
this podcast is nothing short of a >> dude, it's so crazy.
Hold on, I need to go look up the podcast again. Like absolutely
absolutely astroturfing flagrant off the map like destroying
that show. Okay. Um,
and how how many views does her What is What is the podcast called?
Oh, I had it before.
What is her podcast called? I need to see what her podcast is
called. Oh, hold on. Oh, where is it? Can we go to her Tik Tok?
>> Painpoint is really a lack of self-awareness. May think
you're for the Brown Girlies, but if you're saying me,
>> Oh, the act. So, this is Jasine Singh. Hold on. The
Jasine Singh. Where's her where's her video
or sorry, where's her podcast? Main character podcast. Hold on.
So, the main character podcast. I need to see how many subs they
have now because they had 8K when we first looked at this story
and I don't know if it's ever gotten better. Main character podcast.
Oh, not 8K. 1.8.
Dude, no way, dude. Dude, it's still 1.8K subscribers.
Like, nobody is subscribing to this channel. Literally nobody.
Like, she did this to promote her podcast. Nobody subscribed.
Nobody cares. Nobody actually is here to watch their content.
They are. I guarantee you like 800 of these people are also just
turning the bell on. This is the least Oh, it was it was 1k to
1.8. Dude, this is the least successful rage bait campaign. There's
no conversion here at all. There's nothing
is a total joke.
Okay. Anyway, back to back to the Flaco video.
There are new there's new stuff >> Humiliation ritual for
Akash.
It it yo it's such malarkey that I began to think oh maybe her
plan is to embarrass Akash to the point where he embarrassed
her cuz like like obviously no man would ever sit >> oh
I think so Flaco is saying oh maybe she's intentionally and hey
this the only thing that doesn't make sense here if this is the
case is maybe she's trying to embarrass him to the point that
she gets divorced she could go somebody else maybe that's the
goal she's like oh he won't give me a divorce he's not going
to divorce me okay I've I've tried acting like a this whole marriage
I'm barely even a human being. I'm so mean to this guy and he
WON'T DIVORCE ME. I JUST WANT TO leave with my money. Please
divorce me. That's Aasha. Akasha is actually doing some judo.
Okay. He's like, I don't care what you do. You ain't getting
none of this money. I don't care what you do. No, I'm going to
be here the whole time. I'm never divorcing you. I'm never giving
you the money. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nah, [__]
Nah. Do you get half the money? I have no idea what state to
live in. Who knows? Who knows? I'm just saying that's like by
far the best narrative I've heard for what is actually happening.
>> There allow >> you're only married for like a
year. I think they got married when he's 31. I think they've
been together for quite a while at this point. Oh, maybe not
31 cuz they she was she started dating him in flight to tell
them on a podcast in front of him. There's another man sitting
next to Akash on the podcast and she told Akash, "I want to have
an orgy with that man cuz he said no man would tolerate a woman
coming online and telling us constantly that she's with him because
of money." No man would tolerate his virgin wife who he thought
was a virgin coming [clears throat] on that was >> okay.
Okay, Flaco's got some stuff here. I think he talks about it
being an arranged marriage. I'm pretty sure, but
also he's got this is from like somebody who apparently went
this Yekna clip or whatever. Somebody apparently went to one
of Akasha's uh things >> and then like his stand up tab
early cuz the mood got ruined cuz it didn't really feel like
he >> Hold on. I need to back up. >> Yo, it wasn't
funny. It wasn't hilarious. It wasn't something that was like
a comedic goat. No, it was actually I was told dark.
It was >> So, this is talking about his show. He went and
did like a comedy uh like he's on a comedy tour. He's doing a
show apparently. He like barely he like kind of started engaging
with it, then he started ranting and it's like not funny. It's
not happy. Nobody's laughing.
That's like that's like stage five of the meltdown for anybody
who streams, but he's doing it in person live. >> Sad.
It didn't make people laugh.
It actually resulted to him ending like his stand up a tad bit
early because the mood got ruined because it didn't really feel
like he was perfectly okay with it even though he was trying
to appear as if he was okay with it.
>> I've I've seen this post before the is post that took
off on for null. Jesus >> sing addressed the drama with
his wife. He's doing standup shows at Cobb's comedy and someone
who is in the crowd went to Reddit and described what he said.
So, lay, I went to the 7:00 p.m. show last night and it was extremely
awkward. He was clearly not processing the situation well and
he ended the set 20 minutes early. >> Oh, I want to see
I want to see some of the comments. I went to the 7:00 p.m. show
last night and it was extremely awkward. He was clearly not processing
the situation well and he ended the set 20 minutes early. I only
found out about his wife the day of the show and honestly after
seeing that set basically uh basically be his therapy moment
about it. I am way more suspicious of the controversy than before.
This is clearly something he's insecure about even though he
tried way too hard to make it seem like he wasn't. He spent the
first 15 minutes of the set talking about the controversy, how
his wife has been loyal to him and everything she has been saying
is just jokes and is fine with him. No one in the crowd knew
how to take this information and I truly dude you go to a live
show where nobody is like aware of this drama. It wasn't okay.
I I was told it was an arranged marriage. All right, I'll go
back on that one. My bad. Misinfo. Misinfo on my part.
All right. I don't know where I got that from,
like there's a ton of people there. There's got to be a bunch
of people there who only watch Flagrant, only know him from Flagrant.
Might not have caught any of this drama. And he's like ranting
about this drama that happened. That's
Okay, keep going. I truly believe that the majority of the fans
there had no idea any of this was going on. This only made him
spending like one-third of his set on it even more awkward. He
then proceeded to jokingly call his wife a every time he brought
her up, which was not helping. I think it ruined his whole set
and her and the mood never recovered, which is why I think he
ended early. I honestly don't give a [__] about he
or his wife's wife. But if the orgy stuff is really just jokes,
then clearly he's not cool with it and hides it and or she's
just not very funny and no one close to her has told her this
yet. Curious to hear if anyone else went to the later sets and
had a better experience. He's in SF till Monday. Did anyone go?
Yeah, man. Oh, Akos SF show. Yeah, man. I was there. It was a
little odd. He addressed it, but the energy was off. He opened
with some topical stuff relating to the location and news headlines,
etc. After that, he brought a chair out on stage, sat down in
it, and watched as another man his wife. Okay. Then he got into
some material, but only for a few minutes because he got right
into crowd work. I really feel like the crowd work is such a
crutch in modern comedy. I guess Jesus. Sorry. That's I'm sorry.
That was funny. That guy. Listen, that guy's way funnier than
Akasha's wife. Okay, get this guy a podcast. Wheels.
Wheels. Neils. Wheels and Keels. All right, get this guy a podcast
right now. >> I only found out about his
I just went to the show and because he talked about it, I figured
out what was going on and went online and then somehow found
a YouTuber to give the full scope to. But if they're telling
the truth, and this is not somebody who is drama obsessed. They
had no idea what was going on. And when they got there, their
first time hearing about this drama was him talking about it.
>> And he appeared to be very bothered by it. He appears
to not have a good poker face about it. And he actually seems
pretty disturbed. It would make sense. Like it would make sense
that a man is very concerned that the woman who he bragged about,
who he told the world about, the woman he bragged about being
pure and being holy, right, and being religious and being a virgin,
>> unique is to be trusted. Well, it's a Reddit account
that he's getting it from. We just went and looked at the red
pill. He walked down the aisle. That woman now being viewed as
the pinnacle of an absolute slur. It will bother any man, bro.
Especially a guy who has made it his life mission to go against
the red pill to provide himself in his life, right? As an example
of how you could find a good girl if you look the right places.
You look the right places,
That's the other thing about this is he's sort of undone every
bit of help he did by saying, "Hey, Myin, I think your views
are wrong." When Myron came on the the flagrant podcast,
it it's like totally embarrassed himself. Like Myron Myin is
transcendent right now. Myin is like, "I'm correct about everything.
I was always correct about everything." >> And he and he
ended up with the worst possible person on earth. Now, I feel
like Akos is bothered by this and he kind of has to lie about,
you know, it just being jokes because he really has no other
remedies. Like, what can Akos really do with the situation? Don't
worry, >> there's there's way more here. DJ Denkey, apparently
there's there's old clips. Okay, like I said, this guy digs.
There's old clips from early on in flagrant where Andrew Schultz
apparently told her to off out of the room while they're going
to record the podcast and she got really about it. Okay, like
like literally she was doing something on their computer in their
recording studio and he was like, "Hey, why don't you get the
out of here?" And she was really about it. Akos didn't do anything.
Akos was totally avoidant. didn't try to fix anything, right?
But that that clip alone existing goes a long way. >> She
has already made that pretty clear. He can't leave her. Here
is a Tik Tok of her bragging about how her husband can't leave
her. Addressed to the people telling her husband to leave her.
She's saying to everyone saying my husband should divorce me.
Boy, do you got something coming, right? Cuz guess what? Guess
what? We didn't sign a prenup. That right there is her address
to the people telling her to leave her. Believe me, we ain't
sign no prenup.
>> This man married a mastermind, bro. A diabolical mastermind.
[laughter] And right now you got to have that. >> See red
pill talking points. Incel talking points from Flaco go down
smooth from Techone from from Tactical Templar. Not so good.
Okay, this man married a mastermind. She's doing a she's doing
a total hatchet job on this guy. Okay, that that's funny. >> Like
what can he do? Like divorce the chick after finding out what
like her real ways after years of marriage and having to start
over at 40 years old after she takes everything from him. Like
what exactly is he going to do? And why I don't feel like necessarily
bad for Akash is because this chick hasn't really hid anything
from him, right? Because I was watching her TikTok where he's
right next to her. Like he's literally right next to her and
she's talking about a prenup. And you know what I knew? I had
to stop feeling sorry for our costume during this chick's
>> Wait, to be to be fair, I think I don't think that's
her talking about the prenup. I don't think she's talking about
it there. She's doing like a TikTok and then she puts a text
over it, >> She said, "Listen, like if a man asked me for
a prenup, I would never never agree to that. But if I'm getting
married and and I have the money, I would demand he sign a prenup
or else I'm not getting married cuz he's not going to take all
that. So this chick understands what a prenup is for. She >> We
skipped that clip. We skipped that
Like like it's [laughter] >> Okay, that could be a soundboard.
Hold >> About to take from him, bro. Like
Like IT'S IT'S THE WEALTH. >> I I got to watch it. I got
to watch it real time. Okay, one time. Oh, like it's yo, IT'S
THE WEALTH SHE'S about to extract from this dweeb.
She know >> Blackco was floating a longdistance girlfriend
that wouldn't marry or sleep with him. He's worse than Akos,
bro. Everything, dude. How does everybody know everything about
these guys? All of the Everybody who came from No Jumper, they
all talk about their personal in like Discords and stuff. Like,
all of their personal lives are known. Every single element.
How did they Why did they do this? They're all They're all crazy
oversharers. Every single one of them. Yeah. Every single one
of them was like insane. >> She found a lick. She know
she found an easy lick.
>> And it's like damn, >> dude. We dude the point
and shoot guy. I I don't know about the point and shoot guy on
Flaco, but the point andoot guy on Yuri. Oh my god, dude. I haven't
heard anything from Yuri in a long time. We should look up some
If point and shoot's been following Yuri around, dude, that whole
Yuri story with his girlfriend. Holy [__]
That was so good.
>> Damn, bro. Yo, Akash
>> Akash has so much respect cuz he was one of those dudes
where he was rational. He was not an extremist. He's not somebody
where we could look at it and say, uh, right? Like he was just
he was just a normal average guy who had opinions that a lot
of us probably agree with on a lot.
But this situation right here, man, just looking at how much
he got gamed up by this chick, it's like, damn, bro. and is fine
with him.
No one in the crowd knew how to take this information. And I
truly believe that the majority of fans there had no idea. Hey,
that guy's on my favorite podcast. I'll go see him. >> Supposed
to drop. >> That's uh that's
we haven't really heard from them at all.
>> Okay. So, they haven't dropped a new episode of their
main character pod. Okay.
Haven't dropped it. It's supposed to be every two weeks, every
week even. They have not dropped a new podcast episode. I wonder
why a G. I wonder why. >> Akage hasn't really talked about
it yet on Flagrin. I do believe Flagrin has dropped the episode.
I think the last episode was about 3 days ago where they interviewed
somebody. Akos was actually the A mic during that episode. So
maybe that episode was filmed before the controversy. We don't
know. But as of now, he hasn't really discussed it yet. All right.
Now, Indra Schultz is doing brilliant ideas. I think today if
not tomorrow um if they don't talk about it on Brillias then
we know what it is right like if shaman to god and shows don't
discuss this akash thing at all then we know what it is then
we probably know okay like akash has probably sent out you know
the abb hey bro can we not talk about this please don't discuss
this publicly I just want this to go
but if they do talk about it then flag will be a pretty interesting
episode right because
we'll see what is really made up now obviously Andrew Schultz
like Akash loves him, but Andrew Schultz and this chick been
having issues like they been beefing like for a while now. So
Andrew I think like finally gets a chance to be vindicated and
finally gets a chance to say how he really feels about this chick
cuz Andrew been warning Akos about this chick for years now.
>> So Flaco says this. The proof is not great for Flaco's
claim here. Okay. It's like a clip that Andrew had like a bad
moment with her a couple years ago, but the moment is very goofy
when you hear them describe it. Okay. She's like totally entitled
even back then. Um, also, let me see how how long we have on
the clock. Eight minutes, guys. We need uh we need two subs,
I think. Yeah, two subs for another hour on the stream. Uh, guys,
present it to the whole shill. All right. Two two subs. Hour.
We need it. We need it now.
>> Go, go, go. Yo, I literally seen uh when Andrew and
Akash started flagrant like this chick apparently like her entitled
way started way before the internet.
apparently she was doing homework on like the studio computer
and they asked her to leave and she got mad and entitled. They
asked her to stop working on the computer so they can film their
>> hooligans, thank for the gifted sub. Appreciate it,
buddy. Why? What you just Why am I Here we [snorts] go. That
>> rude. Was that rude?
>> Schultz cos sing Lyrant. >> Was that rude? Yeah,
>> it's kind of rude. >> Why was it rude? >> It's
kind [laughter] of rude. >> Was it rude guys? Was it rude?
>> I don't care. I'll deal with I get home. I [laughter]
mean, >> oh, you should leave it in.
>> You should start right. >> Hold on, hold on, hold
on. Rude. Hold on, [laughter] hold on, hold on. Leave it in
>> Andrew looking rough. Well, this is years ago, right?
Before we start, because we already started, but was that rude?
Was that rude? First of all, something that I learned today that
I that I had only heard in rumors prior was that Akash's girl
does not like Young Hezi.
>> Not at all. >> I felt the vibe. >> She don't
like you. [laughter] >> Oh my god. >> No, she don't
like you. >> Not at all. >> Why is that? Oh, and
I and I even gave Akos like a little fake ass compliment like
remember when they were doing a podcast and I was like I was
like man he waited for you like I've been trying to whatever
you know you know how you try to pick you know promote your boy.
>> When she don't like you ain't over.
>> Hey bro
>> I didn't I didn't catch this um when I first watched
I just listened to this a little earlier to see if I'd watch
it on stream. This is a good clip right?
Like Aasha is literally saying she doesn't like you. I'm guessing
that's because Andrew caught the game. Okay. Andrew probably
caught the game. Warned Akos. Akos might have said something
and then Hey Andrew, I don't She doesn't like you. I don't know
what to say. I'm not
>> This sounds like jokes. >> I'm not going to hold
you. I felt the >> The vibes were there. But wait, was
that rude when I just said we'll wait for Akasha's girl? I said
we'll wait as long as she need it. We'll wait. >> Dude,
this I I'm sorry. Everybody just tries to say, "Oh, it sounds
like jokes." It all sounds like jokes. They're saying no, it
was rude. He's he's saying that we're they're sitting down to
record the podcast and he looks over at Akasha's wife or Akasha's
girlfriend and says, "Don't worry, we'll all just wait for you."
Yeah, obviously that's rude. Obviously, you're being a dick,
but maybe you you need somebody who's going to be a dick. Sounds
like sheets to be told, "Hey, it's [__] rude. We're
trying to record a podcast. We're all here. You're not a part
of the podcast. Get the [__] out of here." >> You
didn't say it like that. [laughter] >> That's not how you
said it, >> but that's how I meant. What?
And he's doing the performative. Oh, well, I I wasn't trying
to be rude. I wasn't trying to say get the out of here. I was
just saying like we'll just wait for you as long as you need.
All I wanted to say was we'll just wait for you. Well, everything's
about you. We don't need to. My schedule doesn't matter. It's
all about you. We'll just wait for you as long as you need. Guys,
was that rude? Oh, that's what I meant. What do you mean it sounded
sarcastic? What do you mean? >> How'd it come out? like
get the gap. >> All right, we'll wait. >> I Oh, was
like, "All right, we'll wait." >> It's the all right, we'll
wait plus the pause cuz she like, "All right, we'll >> And
then just stare at you. >> I don't know what she was she
What was she? She She was doing homework or something. [laughter]
>> So, you take her all she was doing work. >> You
went through.
>> Uh Marvin, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. What?
Hour five. Let's go. >> I just looked over the computer
and looked like she was coding or some [__] and I
was like, "Bro, we got a podcast to do. It's already quite late,
you
>> He's saying he's trying to say, "Oh, no. I was like,
oh, I was just trying to be nice." No, you weren't. Everything
else he says is so obvious that he was like upset that she was
sitting there trying to
trying to like actually This is a green room for Andrew's live
comedy set. Okay, cool. I He's trying to pretend that he is
not kicking her out, that he's like not um that he's not trying
to record the podcast and like tell her to off. And then he's
like, "Well, guys, it's late. Like, we have a podcast record.
It's already getting late. He obviously wants her out.
Um, so this was a green room for Andrew's live comedy set. Does
that mean that this was during the comedy set? Sorry, like right
before the comedy set, or are you saying this is a green room
as in a writer's room? Because a green room is usually where
you wait before you go do something live, right? But I Does he
have like a comedy
like bar? Does he have like an actual Yeah, like a a comedy set?
I don't know what the What am I trying to say? like a podcast
green room. Yeah, something like that. I don't know what you're
saying.
Like
he has a comedy I I want to say comedy store, but that's not
that's a place. What do you call it? A comedy club. Does he have
like a comedy club? Yeah,
dude. This thing's getting worse. I swear to God. This like aphasia
I get sometimes. It's like actually getting worse. Very upset.
Before Andrew's live comedy set.
Okay, that's cool that they set this up to record here. Probably
because they didn't have time to go back. What year is this from,
Nick? Do you know >> Obie is a very entertaining interview
>> AI? Nick is saying that it's before his live comedy
set. You're saying this specific instance is right before his
comedy set or did they own a studio here that they used to podcast
from?
>> That's what makes you a
wild go. I'll be like if I was my girl like we'd have to have
words. [laughter] >> Why you Why are YOU SPICING THIS UP?
>> IT UP like
>> that's rough when you got a buddy. This guy is not innocent.
Okay. This guy is not innocent. He just called Aasha a [__]
You caught that, right? That he just openly called Aasha [__]
right
I think we all We all caught that. Nobody missed it, right?
If Yeah. If that was me, we'd have to have words. I'd have to
have a problem with you. Okay. But luckily, you said it to this
girl. You said it to this girl and this won't defend his girl.
Okay. If it was me, I'd have to say something about it. Luckily,
I can just sit here and laugh at this [__] Yo, a
[laughter] explain to me what's going on cuz I don't get >> And
now you're pinning a against me. Like he got >> I'm not
putting nobody's
in the corner. I know. >> Hold on. Hold on. No, you definitely
>> I was just like, [laughter] >> yo, Akash, explain
to me what's going on. I don't get it. >> And now you're
pinning a gets me like he got I'm not putting nobody against
Cass in a quarter. I know you high or >> I'm not I'm not
high at all. I'm super sober. He's like just been super chill.
>> No, I was I was I had to watch the show,
>> dude. I I'm sorry. He is That was diabolical. Okay,
I was right. >> It's kind of crazy cuz when this happened,
you could go back and read the comments. Everybody was against
Andrew Scholes, not really understanding who Akashing's girlfriend
is and or or how problematic Jasine could be. But now looking
back, Angel was 100% right, bro. And Angel Sch was 100% justified,
bro. Like that. Yo, that right there just falls in line with
who we think Jasine is, right? Inconsiderate, problematic, bro.
Storming out, closing the door, slamming doors, being upset that
they told you, "Hey, you can't do homework here. We have to film."
But let me know in the comments section, man. What do y'all think
about this, bro? All right. Y'all think Akash
is savable, man? Do y'all feel like Akos knows what he's doing?
>> Let me know, bro, cuz this is sad, man. >> Okay,
hold on. I got to go. I got to go see. Okay. God forbid you take
my citizenship. And >> what's what's the latest video?
>> God forbid you take my citizenship. >> Let's take
a look. I I have >> 4.9K people bombing it with dislikes.
Okay. Just bombing it with dislikes.
Who' have guessed that? A Kasha's funniest joke ever was, "My
wife is a virgin."
[laughter] The top comment on the whole podcast.
All right. Gosh. Still trying to use Okay. It trying to use the
it will blow over in a few days strategy. We are not going to
stop talking about it until you do. Mr. I can only kiss my wife
on the cheek is hurting behind that fake ad laugh. We getting
the Epstein files before you get the Akos files. Akos is the
Indian Will Smith. Please don't let your future son bring his
friends around. [laughter]
dude. This is like this got to be rough cuz you know that people
watch this because they want like insight into the comedy scene.
Like it's a bunch of people who either are too scared to try
to take a run in comedy or are aspiring comedians who watch this.
So, you know, the comments are going to be kind of up,
right? Bro married the Indian town bicycle. Flagrant dodging
the Akos controversy like Jasine dodges his kisses. My wife is
a virgin is one of the best jokes Kakos has ever said. At this
point, I think Akos is still a virgin. [laughter]
Hold on, hold on. We got I got I'm going to keep reading until
we get something that's not about Akash's wife or referencing
it. Okay, who else clicked on the video, pushed pause, and went
straight to the comment section? Me. We need the white boy. Wait,
frat boys on the pod ASAP, dude. Oh, you know, you know Flaco
or somebody is trying to figure out where she went to college,
trying to find out who was in the frats at that time. She going
to he's going to try to find somebody who popped that. Okay.
Who helped her pop that?
Black's in the in He's grinding. Okay. He's going to figure it
out. This might be the only time everyone everyone's joke gets
1k likes instantly.
Dropping two episodes in one week isn't going to make everyone
forget about what we really are here. But what we really are
here to see. So like Schultz says, anybody can get these jokes
unless it's
Only thing longer than a flagrance guest list is Akash's wife's
roster. Can we get Akos divorce lawyer next? 100 likes and Jasine
is the next guest. Sometimes I get so painfully nostalgic for
college. [laughter] No praying up. It's over. Ver dodging the
AOS controversy like Jasine dodges kisses. The internet never
forgets. Ignoring the simp in the room is a flagrant violation
of the comic code d of comic code of conduct. Getting drunk with
Akash's wife while watching this on my lunch break. Akos should
be getting an STD test instead of trying to be funny on this
podcast. Your laugh ain't fooling anyone. Akos, we know you're
going through it, bro. Release the Jaseen files. Akos I'm going
to keep going until I find a comment that is not about Akos Singh
or his wife. Okay. Or referencing the drama. Akos better address
this before his next stand-up tour. The heckler is going to be
popping off harder than Jes's cat at a white boy frat house.
Akos asking if Mo Mary Brown like it helped him in his life is
serious. Lauo, new seating arrangements. He'd have a chair for
a cos in the
I haven't listened to a single word from the guest. Just been
reading the comments for like 12 minutes. Lauo, hey, you me both,
brother. I just knew this the comment section was going to be
all about akos. Either all his drama is a stunt for attention
or my boy Akos is actually going through it. How long is flagrant
going to duck the Akos wife
Came here for the Akos hate. Listen to the podcast for 3 minutes
and I want to blow my head off. So to pause and just look for
comments. Just here for the Akos roasting. At this rate, they
could resurrect Jeffrey Epstein and bring him on. And the comment
section is still going to talk about Akos. Release the Jasine
files. We are not letting it go, y'all. If this was anybody else,
they'd have a 30-minute clip discussing it. I bet you Jasine
is grinning hard while reading these comments. I just came to
see the dog get walked by his wife. I'm just here to see Akos
get roasted in the comment section. Guest idea, Myin Gains. Jasine,
she said she gained 15K new followers from all this, showing
us what her priority is. Akos doing okay, buddy? here for the
Akos comments. One minute in. No one wants to sit beside Akos.
>> You're comfortable, [laughter]
>> dude. Dude, he is kind of off. He is kind of off in
the distance. Oh boy. Oh boy. This is almost in the corner already.
Did somebody rearrange the seats? Was there more cohesion between
the seats before? Have they put him in the corner intentionally
to with him? Oh boy.
I'm not done reading comments. We've not made it through the
comments yet. We down at that one minute one. Hold on. Where
was it? Here. Hold on. We were down at the one minute one.
I've missed it multiple times now. Right here.
I wish people would stop roasting Akos. I don't have enough time
to like them all. Making Jasine the next guest would actually
be the best move they could make. This isn't going to go away,
guys. This needs to be addressed or Akos can never do standup
again. Akos looking like he's hiding a zombie bite from the rest
of his crew. Not addressing the Akos situation is only going
to alienate their viewers. Vagrant would talk about anything
but a cautious controversy. Aos thinking about it all at 5010.
Hold on. I just [laughter] wanted to make you feel more confident.
Dude, the comments are brutal. I just want to Man, I just want
to make it through the comments. Surely I can make it through
these comments, right? They're not just going to go forever.
It's not going to be the rest of the stream, right? Surely you
guys didn't just pay. You didn't just give a whole bunch of donations
for me to keep reading Akos comments.
These white girls joke jokes. Akos makes now hit different. Clanking
bottles on fingers. Akos, come out and play.
Akos's wife should be the next guest. She woke up sore. That's
wild. Akos. Nah, bro. The best show you ever did was pretending
the Jez that the Jazz Lean files didn't exist. We want the files.
We want the Carfax. Wow. You guys aren't letting go, are you?
Question is, is it sustainable? Can we continue the Akos dragging
until they respond? Find out then on the next episode of Kakos
Balls Z. Sorry, Kakos balls. My bad.
Oh, I saw a video on IG that said Akos can no longer do crowd
work in his standup.
Not responding to the Akashi sing Akos Singh wife controversy
is going to be a big problem for this bunch. We want a Kasha's
wife as a guest. Schultz sons always ducking a real fade. Honestly,
really sad to see someone so desperate and eager to gain to attain
what's considered a good-looking woman and attention from the
opposite. He can't even be mad at the internet for not respecting
him cuz he doesn't respect himself, especially after he publicly
criticized other people's relationships and said he would not
love a soft son when bro is the softest comedian on the internet.
Going through the the timestamps and not watching a single video
till Kakos
Kakash announces he's getting a divorce. Holy here and paused
at one second just for the comments and not y'all never disappoint.
Come here for the Kos comments. Don't dis didn't disappoint.
Lol, dude. I Okay, I
Okay, how many comments are there? Holy >> Wait, how many
comments are there? I got to I got to check. Am I doing something?
>> If there's like 40,000 comments, I'm not going to continue.
Okay, there's 3,0004. Surely someone's got to get a comment in
that's not just the same thing, right? Surely I committed. >> I
committed.
I need music, though. I need music in the background while we
do this. This is crazy. Okay.
The more flagrant refuses to address the elephant in the room,
the less interested I am in the guest. Akos cannot weasel his
way out of this one. Flagrant dodging the Akos controversy. Heads
up boys. Good talking point for the red table pod with Kakos
next week. The poopole loophole is a fallacy. I think someone
owes My an apology. Please invite some white frat boys and Jasine
to the next episode and make Akos sit in the corner. Five likes
on the on the next podcast. Someone has to say Kakos and Aesha
chicken curry. Aisha chicken curry. What?
What you reverse control F? I legit haven't seen a single comment
that hasn't been about his wife. We're not letting this go until
they bring it up. So, Andrew is just going to sit there and respect
his friend's privacy. We all know Andrew would have wanted to
make a whole episode laughing at him and his wife. The wife that
plays Gossip Girl in his green room. What a beey.
Myin never misses. He's not so childish now, huh? Switch, switch,
switch. Changing couches like Aasha's wife changes frat boys.
Okay, I just I'm sorry. I got to Dude, it's it's actually the
whole thing. It's the whole thing. It's the whole thing. It's
the whole thing. I can't. I can't. I can't. I can't. I'm sorry.
As much as I want to, I can't. They're turning you into a song.
We listened to the song. It was a good song. Keep going. Somebody
paid for this. They did. Well, not directly.
There's a lot of other content. I'm going to get to other content,
but god damn, dude. God damn. God damn.